Тисячі художників фарбують радянські пейзажі,
корівки, річки...
[російською] Як Айвазовський, живий.
[російською] Шишкіна обожнюю.
Жодного сенсу, тільки майстерність виписування деталей, все.
Таке може бути, але мені це просто не цікаво.
У мене така історія була, що бабуся заходить в арку і така:
«Що то таке? Воно сумне.
Слухай, твої роботи просто змушують мене думати».
Це що, скульптура, чи що?
Га?
Малюнок?
Клас.
Допомагати треба?
Як відрізняється стріт-арт від графіті?
Дивіться, я — стріт артист.
Я малюю якусь роботу, якийсь текст,
котрий можливо прочитати з легкістю.
І десь маленьке моє ім'я у куточку стоїть.
Якщо б я був графітчиком,
я б сьогодні вранці
на цьому паркані просто написав
ось такими от буквами «Гамлет».
Я би просто здох з нудьги, якщо чесно.
Роками писати «Гамлет», «Гамлет»,
різними кольорами «Гамлет», «Гамлет»,
у мене просто немає стільки
амбіцій, просто немає.
Тимчасова перешкода.
[російською] Добре, малюйте.
[російською] Щасливо.
[російською] Гарного ранку.
[російською] Тільки не фарбою, а крейдою.
Раніше ще у 2009-му, 2010-му році, в 2011-му
просто під'їжджає міліція,
все збираєш, їдеш до відділку,
там даєш грошей, тебе відпускають
і ти повертаєшся доробляти свою роботу.
30 доларів — все.
Я на той час на хабарі грошей витрачав приблизно стільки ж, скільки на фарбу.
Інколи більше.
Але я був впевнений, що в якийсь
момент прийде та мить,
коли поліцейські просто будуть
робити з тобою селфі.
Просто треба трішечки почекати.
Так і вийшло.
Коли мене відрахували з академії,
десь на межі, коли мене відраховували,
хлопці, котрі знали, як я працюю,
вони звали мене в свою маленьку компанію робити венеційську шпаклівку.
Хлопці заробляли в день, у Харкові
та по Харківській області,
вони заробляли десь 200-300 доларів на день.
На день!
Це зараз великі гроші.
Такі дуже нормальні гроші.
Такі: «Гамлет, давай».
А я тоді взагалі не бухав,
і супер пунктуальний.
Міг так просто сидіти і працювати,
і скільки треба, стільки працювати.
Їм саме така людина
потрібна була в команду,
тому, що всі інші по-чорному бухали,
чи не чули ніколи про пунктуальність,
чи просто руки не з того місця.
І вони кажуть: «Гамлет, давай,
200 доларів на день, давай».
І я відмовився, хоча
в мене нічого не було.
Ще мене відраховують з академії,
і вони такі знову: «Гамлет, давай,
шпаклівка, давай, гроші, давай,
кожного дня, давай».
Я такий: «Ні, ні, чуваки, я буду займатися...»
«Та будеш ти займатися своїм мистецтвом,
давай трішечки попрацюєш у нас,
а потім вже будеш займатися
своїм мистецтвом».
Я кажу: «Ні, чуваки, так не вийде.
Я почну працювати у вас,
почну звикати до того,
що в мене постійно в кишені є
вільних 200-300 доларів,
і потім я почну збирати на квартиру,
а потім вже на машину.
І вже, бабах, а 20 років, і ти тільки
шпаклівку цю клав анонімну».
Так, у тебе класна квартира,
може навіть будинок якийсь там,
машина є, все.
Але я відмовився, не маючи жодних фінансових підстав
відмовлятися від такої пропозиції.
І я дуже радий, що я не погодився.
Дуже радий.
У мене є дуже серйозний цензор внутрішній,
що я можу сказати на вулиці,
а що я не можу сказати на вулиці.
Це вдома я можу намалювати
будь-яку картину,
а на вулиці — ні.
Я думаю про те, що малювати на вулиці.
Вдома я теж думаю, що я малюю,
але на вулиці я розумію, що цю роботу
будуть бачити дуже різні люди,
різного віку, різного розуміння.
І щось я можу сказати для всіх, а щось ні.
Намалювати якусь картину,
котра буде на виставці — окей.
А на вулиці — ні.
Про маленьких людей, така історія...
Це моя найулюбленіша історія щоб показати,
що маленька людинка може бути
взагалі не маленькою.
Це був, я навіть не пригадаю який рік.
Це моя перша подорож до Європи,
десь 2006 рік.
Ми поїхали з виставкою
від Харківської муніципальної
галереї у місто Познань.
При тому ми робили якісь фіктивні документи,
що ми десь працюємо, в нас щось є.
Це смішно взагалі пригадувати,
що займався таким лайном.
І були офіси, котрі робили
тобі за якісь гроші документи,
що ти там власник якогось лайна.
Зараз ти просто береш свій паспорт,
купуєш квиток, і все — полетів.
Важливо просто пам'ятати, як воно було.
Так от, вони нам там показували, гуляли нас,
показували все, що там є в Познані.
І одна штука, котра мені запам'яталася
найбільше за цю всю подорож.
Якесь подвір'я, звичайний спальний район,
значно кращий, ніж у нас,
але спальний район.
І там посеред дитячого майданчику
бронзова скульптура:
стоїть дідок з велосипедом,
з якоюсь сумкою, щось таке.
Чувак працював на заводі,
і в нього було хобі.
Він читав казки різних країн.
Він купував збірники, до прикладу,
«Казки світу», знаєте, там були такі,
і він їх читав, запам'ятовував,
і після роботи він приходив
на дитячі майданчики, читати казки,
розповідати казки дітям.
І він просто після роботи
приходив на майданчик,
годинку читав казки,
і йшов собі далі.
Додому, до дружини, до дітей.
І так просто: одне покоління, друге,
і навіть третє покоління.
Він казки читав щось приблизно
50 років на цьому майданчику.
Це була звичайна людина з заводу.
І коли він помер, люди, котрих
він виховував отакими казкам,
вони всі зібрали кошти
і поставили йому пам'ятник.
Це взагалі історія...
Тому коли я зустрічаю людей,
котрі мені кажуть:
«Я — маленька людина, що я можу зробити?
Я просто ходжу на роботу і все».
Можна і так, звичайно, але...
А от історія теж про маленьку людину.
Але йому просто пам'ятник поставили.
У дворі, де він розповідав ці казки.
Всі перешкоди — вони тимчасові.
Коли роблять загородження з бозна чого,
це ж просто попередження,
що «не лізь туди».
Але звичайно, ти можеш спокійно
перейти он там, там,
просто порвати цю стрічку і все, і піти.
І всі проблеми, насправді, вони тимчасові.
Тому що сьогодні тебе щось хвилює,
а завтра хвилює щось інше.
Сьогодні одні проблеми, завтра інші.
Це нормально.
Велетенський двір, і це схоже
на Женевський автосалон.
Там просто дешевше 50 тисяч
доларів немає нічого.
Але є там тачки якісь Maserati, Maybach,
але там немає асфальту.
Тобто воно на стільки розбите
і ця арка просто жахлива,
вона просто вся отака.
Зрозуміло, там чуваки чекають,
коли влада їм покладе асфальт.
І заходить дев'яносторічна бабуся.
І вона така іде з паличкою, йде,
зупиняється, дивиться на мене,
дивиться на роботу, котру я зробив,
потім на іншу, котра вже зроблена.
І така [російською] «Тьфу,
краще б асфальт поклав».
І далі собі пішла.
Звичайно, краще б я асфальт
поклав у цьому дворі,
але це трішечки не по моїй
професії, класти асфальт.
Ще не доріс.
За осінь, зиму та весну
знищено п'ять моїх робіт.
Насправді ж все не вічне.
Просто стріт-арт дуже швидко зникає.
Але залишаються якісь фотографії,
залишається в людей якась пам'ять,
їх інстаграми і таке інше.
І це дуже приємно, коли ти
сумуєш за якоюсь роботою,
пам'ятаєш, що робота була класна,
але її знищили, там щось сталося.
А потім підходить якась людина, і каже:
«Знаєш, це моя найулюбленіша
робота і жаль, що її не стало».
І так приємно стає.
Думаєш: «О, не ти один переймаєшся цим».
Так, я якось впливаю на людей.
Як саме — я не знаю.
Тому, що коли ти просто
проходиш повз свою роботу,
а там мати стоїть з дитинкою,
котра просто по складах читає твою фразу,
і вони починають з матір'ю спілкуватися:
а що хотів сказати художник.
І мати починає пояснювати
мою роботу, як вона її розуміє.
При тому, що вона не знає, як я виглядаю.
Я просто повз проходив.
І ти просто дивишся на цю дитинку,
котра читає ці фрази в свої п'ять-шість років.
От що з них виросте — я не знаю.
Але добре, що...
Має бути в місті щось,
окрім реклами, це точно.
Ось це точно.
[російською] А що це?
[російською] Не зрозуміло мені.
Тимчасова перешкода.